let's start off with education before we
put your other hat on and let's talk a
little bit about the need to educate
women in this part of the world well
we're pretty convinced that women's
education is key to progress in the
developing world and we think that we
developed the University it's called the
Asian University for women at liberal
arts college cited in Chittagong
Bangladesh we think we have a very
powerful model for delivering that
education focus on critical thinking
problem solving none of this rote
memorization we have a rigorous
curriculum lots of diversity we have
women from 15 different countries that
attend this University would you had
about 370 graduates thus far in Slovak
or 2008 yes yes so we've had three
graduating classes total of 350 yes and
from which countries I mean the whole
gamut yes well they're 15 I could run
through them we started in obviously
Bangladesh Sri Lanka Vietnam Cambodia
Bhutan Nepal Afghanistan view from Syria
China 15 from all over the region okay
how did you get involved well I manage
the rockefeller foundation before i
joined harvard management company and
traveled all over the world with them
and it became pretty obvious that the
key in the developing world was women's
education so that started 20 25 years
ago and at the Rockefeller Foundation I
met Kamala med who's the founder and
visionary behind a UW so when he called
me in two thousand and said I'm going to
do it I knew exactly what I was talking
about it and signed up ok so the thing
is you have a campus which is a well is
you want to build a proper campus during
you that's the thing the government the
Bangladeshi governor's give me the land
have they not yes we have the land right
now we're operating in six least fairly
rudimentary isn't it currently well it's
not term well it's reasonably cheerful
but if we could have a small campus it
would greatly improve certainly the
interactions between student and faculty
allowed us to do a broader curriculum do
more in the sciences
and being able to handle 1200 rather
than 500 students tremendously leverages
this concept now the thing is here you
want to build it out you that doesn't
thing abut so how much money do I see
are you trying to get hold off to do
that well this is day one we're
launching a campaign to raise we hope
about a hundred million dollars fifty of
that to build a small permanent campus
50 for an endowment for stabilization
and 50 to cover the costs of ramping up
from 500 to 1200 okay that you've
attracted already i think the Gates
Foundation ikea even whole gamut of
other people right now so they're all on
board now to invest more in your view
well we hope that they'll be on board as
I say this is early days this is day one
so we'll see but we hope we can put this
together last question on this very
quickly you know this is male a lot of
these societies in this part of the
world a male-dominated how well does an
all-women's College really prepare them
for that well one of the things that
were very sensitive to because we admit
that that is the case is during their
stay at a UW each of the women will have
at least one internship and many of them
have two or three internships so that
gives them a taste to the real world
let's put your other hat on I mean can't
a convexity Capital Management you can't
help but not notice what's been going on
here and I'm sure they've not been
affected by the whips oil markets what's
your take on this well we've had a spat
of volatility in the equity markets not
much in the fixed income markets and
you're not going to get a market
forecast out of me I don't think anybody
knows and I think investors should
invest as though they don't know just
stay long term stay diversified keep
these down keep taxes down all right and
this little spat of volatility will
eventually cease I mean ten percent
Corrections are not that unusual